pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sous un ciel de brume et de pluie le
baltika a fait son entrée à new york
devant des pancartes pour le moins
inamicale
il s'est rangé aux quais 73e' dessous la
rouille et la crasse et c'est sous les
verrières crever que monsieur
khrouchtchev a touché le sol américain
au milieu d'un déploiement de policiers
de garde du corps et de détectives
américains et soviétiques pour se frayer
un passage au milieu des flaques d'eau
et des bousculades
nous sommes loin de la réception de l'an
dernier si intensément plein de l'espoir
d'une détente
[Musique]
presque en même temps étaient arrivés à
l'aéroport un autre personnage de marc
fidel castro on trouvait de seebach bout
d'os est accueilli par les ovations de
quelques 4000 profit d'elliot cubain
d'origine pour la plupart monsieur coup
de chef avait sa forme des meilleurs
jours détendu ironique souriant il
tenait conférence sur conférence même du
balcon du siège de la délégation
soviétique il entretenait un dialogue
avec la foule des envoyés de la presse
internationale le cadre de l'onu
généralement assez solennel et même
qu'on passait devait avoir le spectacle
de la rencontre khrouchtchev castro
empreinte d'une amitié vraiment
débordante tout était prêt les acteurs
étaient en place on attendait les trois
une assemblée de choix monsieur novotny
président de la république
tchécoslovaque monsieur gomulka le
leader polonais
quito chef de la yougoslavie est
également les représentants des 14 pays
nouvellement admis à l'onu parmi
lesquels 11 sont d'anciens territoire
français et ont été présentés par la
france ce sera d'ailleurs la réponse aux
accusations de colonialisme lancé par
khrouchtchev aux français
et voici eisenach le président des états
unis est venu faire devant l'assemblée
des 96 nation son testament politique
dont la partie principale est consacré à
l'aide aux jeunes nations d'afrique
c'est à une sorte de plan marshall de
l'afrique qu'eisenhower voudrait attaché
son nom est appliqué ces derniers
efforts de secours chef ne devait pas
faire attendre sa réplique
après avoir fait l'éloge de l'eau
minérale soviétique dans un discours
fleuve et que monsieur r ter devait
qualifier d'incendiaires il reprenait
avec force ses thèmes habituels et
attaquer la structure des nations unies
et la séance continue
rien n'est fini au congo les
rebondissements continue à se succéder
le colonel mobutu a mis en place son
gouvernement d'étudiants 27 jeunes gens
de 26 à 30 ans commissaire techniciens
qui se défendent d'être des ministres se
préparer et essayer de remettre les
choses en place
cette création n'a pas empêché monsieur
lumumba de faire état d'un accord de
réconciliation avec monsieur kasavubu
pour se déclarer le seul gouvernement
légal
ajoutons d'ailleurs que monsieur
kasavubu dénis absolument la réalité de
cet accord
de son côté à elisabethville monsieur
tshombe président du katanga qui l'a
érigé en état indépendant a déclaré
c'est au tour de la liberté de la patrie
katangaise que se regrouperont les
autres peuples africains du congo
lorsqu'ils auront fini de s'entre
déchirer cependant dans ce même katanga
à 650km d'elisabethville des bandes de
la tribu des balles ou bas partisan de
longue date ont déclenché une émeute qui
a fait plus de 70 morts des bâtiments
publics ont été incendiés
[Musique]
la sphère congolaise n'est pas fini on
attend la suite
mexico pendant ce temps était tout au
souvenir du prêtre miguel hidalgo y
costilla qui voici 150 ans proclama
l'indépendance mexicaine
au programme de cette commémoration un
imposant défilé militaire auquel
assistent et des représentants de tous
les pays occidentaux
mais aussi l'illumination d'une des plus
célèbres place de mexico le soca
[Musique]
c'est dans ce décor que le président de
la république a présenté à la foule le
drapeau national comme le fit voici 150
ans le premier leader mexique à lorsqu
il proclama l'indépendance de sa patte
[Musique]
au pont qui enjambait jusqu'ici le rhin
entre strasbourg et kehl vient de se
substituer le moderne pont de l'europe
un fait banal et pourtant 1939
edouard daladier en culotte de cheval
venez visiter ceux qui montaient la
garde haut rhin comme on disait
l'oeil rivé sur l'autre bout du pont
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
juin 40 avait été fatale au célèbre pont
de kehl
il était là depuis 50 ans et ce n'est
qu'en avril 1945 que le génie français
réinstallera pour réunir les deux rives
du rhin un double pont bailey qui
inaugurera le général de lattre de
tassigny
[Musique]
des blockhaus qui reste aujourd'hui sur
la rive française vestiges de cette
époque mouvementée
on vient de voir s'ouvrir le nouveau
pont de l'europe inauguré par monsieur
robert buron ministres français des
travaux publics et son collègue allemand
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais entre ce huitième pole drame
moderne qui a été voulue comme le trait
d'union de l'europe et le pont de kehl
de 1939 que deux pages d'histoire à
paris installations des commissions
d'élus au secrétariat général pour les
affaires algériennes s'est réunie la
première des commissions d'élus chargée
de l'étude des problèmes de rénovation
rural accueillis par monsieur roger
maurice mademoiselle site kara et
monsieur de l'ouvrier accompagné
monsieur michel debré venu en inaugurant
solennellement cette session souligné
l'importance que le gouvernement attache
à cette procédure basée sur la ligne
politique ainsi défini dégagé par des
élections sincères les hommes qui ont le
plus qualité pourparlers ont des
algériens former des cadres apte à
prendre des responsabilités développer
l'algérie sur le plan économique social
et culturel
[Musique]
le tour de france automobile est encore
cette année l'une des épreuves les plus
importantes du calendrier international
un tour de france qui fait l'école
buissonnière puisque les pilotes environ
plusieurs frontier
[Musique]
en attendant c'est sur le circuit
d'auvergne près de clermont ferrand que
les concurrents s'affrontent sans souci
du décor il est vrai que pour les
pilotes qui ne sont pas des poètes le
mot décor n'a qu'une seule signification
accident
la ferrari numéro 157 de willy mairesse
et georges berger avale les kilomètres
sans autre préoccupation que la moyenne
horaire
[Musique]
biarritz tout le monde descend
maintenant mais restent hébergées les
vainqueurs du tour de france vont
pouvoir enfin profiter du décor comme de
simples touristes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ceci pourrait être un jet d'eau mais
c'est avant tout une oeuvre d'art ainsi
du moins autant son créateur un
ingénieur passer avec armes et bagages à
l'art abstrait pts aujourd'hui en
allemagne on peut admirer toute une
collection de ses oeuvres
essentiellement composée de vieilles
bicyclettes et de voitures d'enfants
usagers magistral mécanique au
fonctionnement 100 m
ces parfaites création d'un esprit
poétique sont alliés aux capacités d'un
magnifique bricoleur
[Applaudissements]
et le plus merveilleux de ces machines
perfectionnées c'est sans doute qu'elles
ne servent exactement ailleurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]